the first words out of your mouth after
you hear can a man come on no we need
the full pundit class to at least assess
things as honestly as possible so I was
always I was also glad to see this clip
this is from Matt Walsh at the daily
wire who's I think certainly been a big
Trump supporter at least on the cultural
issues uh and he took it to Trump on
that uh trans answer
well it goes without saying that there's
no reason to hesitate on the can a man
become a woman question
and there shouldn't be any answer other
than no okay if you're saying anything
other than no
anything the first words out of your
mouth after you hear can a man come on
no
then you can you can elaborate on how
crazy that idea is
first word should be no
anything but an immediate no is a wrong
answer and also an embarrassment and if
if that doesn't if you don't see why
that is then just imagine any other
basic scientific question getting that
kind of answer so what if you know just
to show you how ridiculous this is
imagine if Megyn Kelly had for some
reason asked
um do you believe in gravity does
gravity exist
and then Trump had said
[Music]
um
all right well listen in my opinion uh
you know there are some who say that
human beings can fly uh but I think
probably not
what what kind of answer is that
why in my opinion but first of all
people are focusing on the um part of it
in my opinion
you don't need to qualify something like
this by saying in my it's not your
opinion okay just like it's it's not
when I say gravity exists that's not my
opinion so in my opinion gravity in my
opinion uh the sun is bigger than the
earth
it's not my opinion that's just a fact
it's not an opinion at all
so that was a weak and convoluted answer
where clear and concise is needed when
you as the Republican FrontRunner give
an answer that makes it sound like a
complicated question
you are that is just you
that that that's you surrendering to the
left on that issue
you know what it is you know what it is
it's a substitution of values right when
you go
um in my opinion what he's doing there
in his brain is he's trying to work out
something because in Trump's mind there
he's extrapolating a gajillion things
she asked me a very obvious question I
know the answer to the obvious question
it's the answer that Humanity has known
throughout its history the Millennia but
he's been doing this game instead of
doing what is true what are connected to
his values and Truth he's doing a weird
political game and that is not what
Trump would have done in 2016 so I
absolutely disagree that Trump is
stronger now now that polls may not
reflect that but the man and the ideas
and the thing that's driving the
movement it just is not as strong